so um quick show of hands who here has
heard about flight before
oh nice of you know the few of you is
anyone running flight in production
oh amazing we didn't talk this is pretty
awesome this is uh I'm just asking this
because this talk will be we have an
introduction to what evenflight is and
then we'll get you know our hands dirty
if you want to follow along that's what
uh
stories for so let's go talk about
flight
first a little bit about myself uh I am
the engineering manager for the USS team
at Union AI
we're going to talk a little bit about
you know what union is
but I've been doing software and
straddling you know the border between
like infra and product for for a long
time and
I just love the idea of Open Source the
fact that you know we can be so
successful so helpful to people all
around the globe really it's
it's an amazing idea so
first let's change users Union
what is the union
um
it's a company that was founded to help
people
leverage flight in their you know their
own problems
we want to ensure that people can use
flight without having to worry too much
about the infrastructure if you're
curious go to union.ai
about Union let's talk about flight
first what is flight why did we even
build flight
in the first place so
let's talk about the usual you know life
of the machine learning engineer
you have some data set that you want to
um
derive some insights from you know you
write your usual uh loop or hey I have
this idea I have this argument I want to
try out
you do it in your laptop you scale it
out to production hey now yeah I want to
do distributed training using you know
Pi torch or Ray or whatever finally get
to production start to Monitor and you
go back right the one who's been doing
data science so machine learning
has gone through these Loops for
you know a long time
at flight we understood that hey there
is there's there is a certain way of
looking at this problem that really it
means it's three things machine
learnings or machine learning pipelines
and under the covers they're really data
pipelines data is essential you know the
software is
the problem with like we've been
developing
um strategies and techniques to deal
with software for the longest time but
data is complex and
stateful
uh
things change Jada your mother's
deteriorates you you need to to have a
way to capture that discrepancy and here
where flight and some other tools in
that space they come in that's why we
built for a bit you know
just look around the ecosystem across
all the different steps in the machine
learning and data space just like
gigantic there is no one text box
solution
if you think about you know how to
um
really look at any any any of the
process how do you load data to like how
to even do training how do you serve how
do you run experiments how do you
monitor them
so flight looks at this and proposes a
solution the Second Challenge really is
um you are you're out of a team you're
developing you know your models your
data sets but if you don't have a
structured way to go and iterate through
through this Loop you're gonna have a
hard time so
examples of problems hey you might have
uncached data or
unvalidated data which is even worse
um sometimes you know who here hasn't
been on a team that you have this data
scientist this person's brilliant
but their code only works on their
machine or like in a specific you know
setting
you want reproducibility you want a way
to take that that model and so that it
can run anywhere right
when we get to production you have you
know model you're monitoring you're
evaluating the the results but
how do you track what's happening you
know what if there's some data drift
happening like you need a way to
um
add structure to the iteration process
when it comes to machine learning models
and data
but that's you know what we've talked
about in challenge two it revolves
around the single team structure you
know like you have a team multiple
people but like
this problem only gets worse when you
have different teams working different
parts of the of the pipeline right so
um flight also recognizes that you need
to have a way to establish contracts
establish a way for you know multiple
teams in a big order to communicate and
um and work together
the moment you start thinking about you
know machine learning models that are
big you
as the data scientists are you know
machine learning engineer
um
you need to start thinking about infra
it's just you know how we are or where
we are in the album right now there is
no way to just say hey yeah I have this
beautiful idea let me run it on a
thousand machines like it does not work
like this there's no solution or
textbook solution again go back to that
idea of you know having a way of doing
this
um
that that idea of an abstraction
extracts to to crack away to really
break if you need
um
more resources to train and run your
your workloads
finally you know there's there's a lot
of solutions out there that let you
express computation but in a static
manner like there's no way to run stuff
like like run a grid search where you do
you want to do a hyper product
optimization and you have like different
um parameters that you want to you want
to pass through through a specific graph
so
flight also recognizes this problem and
we propose a solution
orchestration orchestration really is
the answer to these five challenges they
orchestrators out there
and this includes and Clyde
they let you express computation in in
um in an ergonomic way
where you go from you know you have this
raw data you turn it into your desired
State and here by desired State I really
mean any part of the machine learning
chain line from Models to monitoring to
experiment tracking
for all for each one of these five
challenges this is this is what I really
would love to see in an orchestrator
I want to be able to use whatever tool
is appropriate for the problem you know
in the data science and in machine
learning space like python really is
King but you were we're starting to see
you know people using different
languages different Frameworks like what
if we had a way of accommodating all of
that in in a single system right
I want out of the box support for you
know all things virtually lineage cache
immutability like this will help me
build these bulletproof Pipelines
what if I I also really need to
acknowledge that a model doesn't exist
in a vacuum you have multiple teams in
large orgs working with machine learning
pipelines so I I need to recognize this
fact and design around it
I really want a way of
expressing my requirements in a
declarative way so that I don't have to
worry about hey am I running with five
gigs of memory with this versions versus
Pi torch and I want I want a more
abstract level that lets me Express what
it what are my requirements in a more
declarative
Manner and finally
static dags are great but I I need a
notion of dynamism when it comes you
know to more complex algorithms so
let's take a look about talk about how
fly tackles some of these these
challenges
um this graph has a lot so we read it
from left to right on the top left you
see I'm mentioning tasks and workflows
we're going to talk a little bit about
what they mean in a second but
think about this as your as your
pipeline here on the on the bottom left
there's a small bag you know five nodes
doesn't doesn't do much but
um flight gives you a simple way to go
from having your code expressed you know
here using python all the way through a
kubernetes cluster with you know the you
know Tendencies matte and parallelism
controlled by you and
what what instances you want to run this
on so we we go from having code on
someone's laptop yeah we know you have
your your dag expressed using testing
and workflows all the way through
um pods running in a kubernetes cluster
and flight gives you this this layer in
the middle that gives you
um versioning and in a way to track you
know what are what are the actual tasks
that are are running
we do this by a process of that we call
packaging in registration so
what I mean by this is uh you have this
two-step process where you first you
containerize your your code so
the The Little Whale at the bottom there
and see now a bunch of Docker images
that
um
you create based on your code and
there's some flight specific
configuration that teaches quote unquote
how your uh your dag should be run run
on the real kubernetes cluster
when you go through this two-step
process we produce the graph in the
middle the thing in purple here which is
essentially uh the flight's notion of
how your dag looks like and eventually
this gets fed into a kubernetes cluster
that you know schedules your your
computation
let's add more meat to these bones so
let's talk about tasks tasks are the
smallest unit of computation in flight
so they are containerized they are
version and they are strongly typed so
um
here I'm talking about something very
abstract you know like a task really is
just a bunch of python code but in
Flight we give you a way to express like
types in the SDK itself this will become
important you know very very soon but
again this idea that
task is the smallest computation unit
it is containerized it gives you
versioning for like or I think that runs
and it's also strongly typed
you take tasks and you compose them in
workflows so again this idea of strong
strong being strongly typed you know so
workflow is a composition of tasks but
workflows themselves they are also
strongly typed they're also versioned
they
um
they take care of flowing the the data
between
um the the tasks
you don't have to worry about expressing
you know hey this tasks output is piped
into this other task
tasks input like flight figures out for
you
we also have launch plans it's just a
way for you to
um customize and schedule the invocation
of workflows
important finally Dynamic workflows it's
the
it's a way for you to compose
a workflow at runtime remember that idea
that we talked about static decks are
amazing but sometimes you need a notion
of dynamism
Dynamic workflows give you that
projects in domains are also a
first-class citizen in the flight
programming model that gives you that
that clears collaboration between teams
you know you have you have projects and
you have domains and you can use this to
help different teams work on you know
different pipelines and you just
basically stratify this by
using the the combination of
translational domains
all nice and fine but like you probably
have seen similar ideas in a lot of
other orchestrators out there
what's unique about flight
first of all
um here I'm describing a workflow
composed of two tasks and if you read
the can you see the red arrow there so
here I'm describing a workflow this is
the
the white box there takes an input an
integer
it pipes that integer into a task that
I'm calling here create data set that
task has an input a single integer at
output say data frame
if that data gets fed into a second desk
that I'm calling here drain model which
takes a list of dictionary as an input
see that the types they don't match
flight will give you this piece of
feedback
at the moment of registration it won't
even even if you schedule this kind of
computation on a kubernetes cluster
which you know that idea of being
ergonomic having really helping the
developers get this feedback as soon as
possible
it's a feature that that flight gives
you
um also the framework is language
independent our main SDK is in Python
but nothing prevents you from from
writing your computation you know your
tasks and workflows in other languages
Spotify maintains the Java SDK that you
know structure fancy but
we also have ways for running what we
call Rock containers which really as the
name suggests it's up to you to describe
how to
inputs and outputs which gives you the
power really to use literally any
language rust here
if you feel feel free
um here I'm just describing a workflow
that you know it uses a bunch of
languages
Frameworks like hey it takes the first
task at the top there handles you know
spark data frames hands them to you know
a task running python Arch which also
are finally feeds that into a task that
is running in the AWS sagemaker
this it just hints at this idea that you
can call external services in in your
flight workflows
another powerful idea that I think it's
uh it's a feature that is it well
integrated into flight like you have
this this really simple way of
um declaratively
expressing your dependencies you know
here I'm again you know example of a
workflow composed of three tasks and in
each one of these tasks we're running a
different Computing platform
so um first task here it runs on a on a
spark cluster and on the right hand side
I'm emphasizing that flight really is
taking care of the speeding up and
tearing down of the each of the
Computing platforms so in this case uh
your workflow spins up a spark cluster
runs your task tears it down pipes the
data to the next uh next task you know
Pi torture I drew some some training
using pytorch
also that thing runs on a specific set
of nodes that contains like you know
your GPU pool and finally
um you hand that back to a task that's
that runs
um on a ray cluster you know you're
doing something Fancy with with some
machine learning model great flight is
agnostic it really lets you express this
kind of computational declaratively and
I'll put more meat into those bones like
what I mean by this when we get to the
tutorial portion of this this task
um finally and this is I think it's one
of the the biggest features that flight
gives you for free is this idea that you
don't have to worry about how the data
is shifted when it's moved and um when
you're expressing your computation you
know again a simple example here we have
where we have flow that's composed of
two tasks one runs on a spark cluster
another one runs you know on a pie torch
a bunch of gpus flight does the heavy
lifting of converting from let's be
super specific here like Pi spark data
frames into like Pi torch and you don't
have to worry about it you don't have to
like write that code that serialization
code
some people they are using flight you
know Spotify does their accounting for
forecasting
um for those who don't know it's doing
early detection of cancer using ml it's
great using flight
uh black shark is doing 3D mapping of
the the world processing and a crazy
amount of data they also use flight
Kojak doing price optimization Rider
matching in in Asia
great now
um let's get our
our hand story
we're gonna work through 11 examples of
um
a very very simple machine learning
pipeline that uses the polymer Penguins
data set
we
have these three different species of of
penguins and we want to create a model
model that predicts
what is the species given like the the
bill length and build depth is you know
how the data looks like I just didn't
want to use the iris data set I want to
do something a little bit more
interesting
oops but it's chill time
uh if you want to follow along please
hit this URL
findurl.com slash
Pi data Seattle Dash 2023-tutorial
um
I'll switch
this will land you on
this GitHub repo
that contains a bunch of files
if you scroll to the bottom
go to setup here is the zoom okay
okay cool I'll bump it just once
so um
you have two options see if you want to
follow along
um Union has this idea of a hosted
sandbox which is essentially a a small
flight cluster
that allow you to you know play with
flights
it won't let you run anything super big
but at least for for the the examples
that that I have today that's plenty
enough
um you can go to through
sandbox.union.ai
you have to sign up with your GitHub or
Google account I don't know if we added
Microsoft
oh I'm already signed in but sorry if
you want to follow along hit there you
probably see you see this screen that
let you uh start a sandbox
once you hit that you can click on code
editor that will bring you to this
sort of
UI this is vs code running on the cloud
you don't have to you know really
install anything again you just want to
get a taste of what flight is
um
the other option if you
you want to um
run this in your local box or you want
to run you know more more complex
workflows
in the same
instructions I have a local section here
that lets you you know install this
locally you have a self-contained flight
cluster
it won't bring your machine down or
anything it just runs kubernetes inside
of a Docker container
and um
this is what I'm gonna do to
demo and go through the rest of the
tutorial so here
just just I put the theme has set the
team as as white just because I think
it's it's easier on the eyes
it's probably better great cool so from
how long
um as I said we have 11 examples again I
don't know if the zoom is okay I'll just
increase this
I think it's fine
well there's 11 examples that will go
through you know the five challenges
that we talked about
um how do we do with scalability with
flights like how do you handle data
quality reproducibility
flight houses is great
feature that lets you recover from
system problems you know so that you
don't you're in the middle of a five-day
training job and something goes wrong in
your kubernetes cluster like flight
gives you a lot of flexing flagging how
to recover from that
and we go through some auditability
exercises so
feel free to follow along uh
instructions will just install the
um
the flight sandbox that I was just
mentioning but first
let's go and take a look at some code
for real
is this I'll just increase this a little
bit great so
as I said we're going to use the
Penguins
data set
um it's
not a complicated you know logistic
regression that we're going to let I
hear it uh
simple python function takes the the few
parameters hyper params how big is the
test size so that you know how we how
you split the data in some random state
for why why not
um
we do get the data this is uh just
loading the the former Penguins data set
split it
trainer model evaluate compare that with
with tests and return it so really like
nothing nothing out of the ordinary here
we've written you know this kind of code
all the time if you played with machine
learning or you are a practitioner in
the field
and if you look look at this like this
is just python right you're just like
calling a bunch of python functions
what's special about flight
um let's
run this on the flight
um
these
instructions don't really matter
let's take a look at this code first
so
you have
um what I'm calling here remote which is
just a way for you to programmatic
programmatically interact with a flight
cluster
these will essentially get a connection
to the Flight Club running in my local
box
and we are calling executing SQL
workflow passing some function which is
the function that we're just talking
about now and you know specifying some
inputs
we'll see what the console means in a
bit better oh let's
kick this one off
and go over take a look what flight
looks like so
this is the smallest product as well
great so
um
at this point the the first option that
we call in the uh in our workflow get
data
here
which you know 40 intensive purposes it
just looks like a a function call
is running on a on a real low
kubernetes cluster
and
notice how if you go to the graph View
flight produces this visualization of
what your workflow looks like so you
don't have to you didn't have to do
anything to get a sense of you know how
how your workflows look like
um
you can click on each one each any of
these boxes you get access to the
execution of each task whether it's
inputs and outputs and
some meta metadata or meta information
for like how the task runs it's not
super important now
but the idea is hey you you ran a
workflow that we're calling a simple
zero intro dot training workflow at
version zero like this is user generated
like we decided that
this execution of this the the training
workflow example
has version zero you know you can come
here you know the workflow finished
you can um
you have access to all the data that
flew in and out of each one of these
tasks so let's do a small comparison
here real quick so
if you I think it's Alt
yeah so
take a look at
get data
go to the definition
take a look at the get data get data
returns a data frame
and
um then we get that data frame
pass it to split data which
in its turn
doesn't do anything super special but
the
the type hints here for for the return
type of the of the function
tell us something super important we we
have like split data
gets that you know data frame that you
passed as a as a parameter and splits it
using the other two parameters but like
if you go back to flight and you take a
look at how split data looks like you
the the inputs
they're like the data the random state
test size but take a look at the outputs
now
you can
ins by just inspecting the results of
the the split data task
you can go to your blob storage in here
it's it looks like an S350
address or uran but really this is
running locally it's using media under
the covers but the idea is
you have full control over
every step of your workflow so you could
go back to this this task and just like
rerun it if this is what you want to
inspect and this applies to all the
other steps of of your workflow like
I think this example is not
too
complicated
but look at
um
the structure of of your workflow it
just looks like python you know you
didn't do anything special it's just
like hey here A bunch of functions I I
use these these decorators at workflow
and add task to Def you know what the
tasks and workflows and and for all
intents and purposes if you look at this
code like it's this just it it smells
like python you know
um which means what would happen if I
ran this locally right so
let's um I set a breakpoint here so that
we can inspect some of the the
intermediate states of of these function
calls when you run your workflow locally
so
what happens
right
and I don't think I need it anymore
so
I I'm for those who don't use vs code
um I I'm
we're stopping at this like this year
line 81.
um I just want to show
what are the types of of these objects
that we
we used to describe our workflow
check the types like all of them are of
type promise this is an internal
um promise objects
that flight uses
to give you this contract of you know
the the inputs and outputs like the
types match or you have you have
um a way to delay the computation
so
again
if
we are we're running this locally you
know this is running my laptops it's not
running the flight cluster which gives
you that this ability to experiment
explicitly and very easily
translate your computation to run into a
real flight cluster
just so that I'm not lying if we run
this
wait
get the result here it's a logistic
regression model
again not super important the main idea
here is that we are
you can you have the the freedom to run
on
um flight workflows locally and very
easily use a flight cluster to run your
workflows in in a real flight deployment
and the way we're doing this is by using
um here we're using the programmatic
internet base so we're controlling this
execution we're kicking off executions
using remote flight gives you a lot more
options like you could come back
to
the what we call the flight console the
flight UI and you can launch workflows
from the UI
we also have some CLI
that you can use if you know
kicking off things manually is not your
your thing
but let's try to make this this example
more
interesting
we talked about
the notion of dynamism you know this
need that sometimes you just need to
have a better way of expressing Dynamic
computation so go extend this the simple
algorithm that we're using for this
example and now we're going to add some
some grid search
to find what uh the best type of params
for this simple logistic regression
model
so let's go back to the
how we augment this this workflow
again we have a function calling I'm
calling it tuning workflow here
um
following the the the
zero zero example we got some data split
it
the change here is now we have this
function called to model
that does something more interesting if
you see now using a different
decorator that we call dynamic dynamic
essentially ex lets see you express
um Dynamic computation
more easily so being super specific here
if you take a look at
these four lines that I'm highlighting
we are essentially running
um we have multiple executions of the
training model
um
running in parallel and instead of you
know having a
a static definition for for those calls
notice how we we build this list of
executions on the Fly based on the um
the hyper param grid argument that you
pass when we call tune model
how does this look in practice let's go
back
and um
take a look so
the Y take a look at the the craft model
it looks very similar to
um
the the graph view that we saw for the
the other the simpler example that we
ran so I'm just opening the two
things instead of having just a single
call to train model now we have
um this function that will run the the
um the degrees of the you know calling
train model multiple times based on
um the hyper param
grid argument that we passed which
if we take a look at the X take a look
at the example again
we are passing this list
of
[Music]
um
three elements so just like running
really small
um great search only three combinations
of of parameters but again the idea is
the main idea is that you have
um you have this notion of dynamic
embedded in the in the
um tsdk you don't have to worry about
like expressing hyper parameter grids
with you know other constructs or
reaching out to other other Computing
platforms to to do
um
great search
you have a question
like how is it like so much
comprehension that would normally be
single threaded how does yeah that's a
it's a great question so let's go to the
actual code of dynamic you're
essentially talking about these the four
lines here right
way too much magic right yeah so so
um under the covers what is happening is
that flight is taking this entire
function and building your workflow on
the Fly
so it's not running the the list
compilation and running the actual
computation on on a task the dynamic me
here means that you're building this
workflow
on the Fly and then
flight just takes that that
um dag that you build dynamically and
uses the similar
infrastructure to schedule all those
executions in parallel
does this make sense it's slightly
different than
um than map tasks but we're going to get
there I think this is the next example
yes
we can talk more about it later but
there is
no
um I think it's a fair question you know
there's a lot happening right here like
when when you have when you are
programming using the the flight
programming model
um you need to keep in mind like at
which level of
um
of abstraction you are like when you're
inside of a task that is just some
python code running a container
somewhere but workflows and dynamic now
in dynamic workflows they are there are
these these method descriptions of how
computation look you know so this list
comprehension here essentially
tells flight that you have these small
computation units that need to be
scheduled badge at some point
so each call to train model will run in
a separate container like the actual
computation will run separately you're
not really securing training model when
when you are in a in a dynamic context
um
it's a good question good question no
it's the fact that you're inside of a
context of a dynamic like you were free
to choose whatever
signature for your your Dynamic workflow
it's just it's just that you're building
the dynamic workflow on the Fly that's
the idea of dynamic
exactly yes if you don't do this
then um
so I think if we
go to the definition of frame like train
model is just another task like if you
as you're saying like we're instructing
flight the train model is this
computation unit you know it will run in
a separate environment they're all
running its own separate container it's
just that we're building the dag
dynamically that's the idea
but it's just another dag at the end of
the day where each task becomes its own
um separate
um isolated environment running in a
separate container
that's a good question
um
back to
examples here
yeah you stole the Thunder a little bit
but let's talk about math tasks and what
they mean
um
sometimes
Dynamics are
too general for the kind of computation
that you want to express you know
um
in the case of of embarrassingly
parallel computation
flight provides You by this this
construct that we call a map task and
when you look into the code this is how
it looks like
so
if you go to tune model
yeah so
um
again similar to not how we did in let's
just compare these two side by side
I have two model here you have like this
list comprehension where you return
models but using a map task you can
um
Leverage
python to express your computation
slightly more ergonomic way so here um
you have a map task that takes
similar to you know how how pythons map
function work you take a function and
you take a list of iterables and python
takes the python runtime takes care of
mapping that function over the the input
in Flight We call we have a similar
construct called a map task which also
takes a function
the concurrency is just so you can you
can control like how fast you want to to
run it's not terribly important and it
takes
um
the iterable or iterables that you're
gonna map over so let's go over
what this partial here oops this partial
really means
have a function called
train model
take a look at the the parameters for
you take a dictionary in a data frame
and it just you know
instantiates whole GC regression model
oops
back to training model here
again you have a map task that takes a
function
and here we're
using
um some some python magic to fix one of
the inputs to the train model function
we are saying hey
python create me this partial function
for those who haven't used you know
partial applications in Python Funk
tools the butane it it gives you this
idea of basically freezing arguments to
to a functional application
so
in in the case here we or in this case
we have a partial application of the
train model function or task where we
force data to be the train data
and we map this over the list of hyper
params that we passed in
compare this to how the list
comprehension
looks like in some cases you know it's
it's simpler
or people feel much simpler to use map
tasks just because the intent is
is so much clearer when when you have
these embarrassing parallel computations
right where you have a function and you
have an iterable or as or eater balls
that you just want to map over
um yeah sorry we haven't run this so
let's see
let's take a look at how
this graph looks like and compare that
to to the
the other example
um
again the difference here is the is the
tune model
um
you have when you when we get to model
now you have this this smaller
um
I'll call it smaller dag that just
runs a map task and if you go to the
nodes View
and expand one two model is doing so we
need
give it another second or so
I want to show
that if you click on the on the map task
um description you you see here on the
right hand side that
um you have three
computation units that are running
or need to run and flight is doing the
heavy lifting of you know scheduling
them in parallel
um
obeying or taking into consideration the
um the concurrency that you chose for
your map task execution so this would I
mean
in this particular example this is not
super interesting because we only have
four
hyper parameters
elements in that list so this doesn't
really apply but like
let's say you had you know you're trying
to run a grid search and now you have I
don't know 300
or maybe not that but that hybrid 3 000
combinations of hyper params
instead of you know overflowing your
kubernetes cluster you can you can
control I how many instances of that
computation will be run at any point in
time
make sense
any questions
all right let's
um
let's keep going
flight also has this this idea of
plugins and here I'm using plugin the
word plugin very
Loosely because this this means
very different things depending on you
know what we're talking about so let's
go over small example
so again we're building on the
um the Palmer Penguins example
we have a training Okay so
have a training workflow
that is getting some data which is you
know what we're already
sub assault just so
now instead of you know downloading
um the the file that's provided by the
department Penguins example
where using SQL Lite to actually run a
query hitting this data set example that
has the department Penguins
um data or data sets
notice how you didn't have to change
um any anything in in how you define the
workflow so just to go back to this
let's go back to the X the actual
workflow so
this is the workload that we're talking
about here
it it runs some pre-processing and gets
the data using
um
this function that we're just describing
here
which runs a sqlite query that returns
an object of type type Penguins data set
it runs this query you know just gets
all the data from the Penguins table
flight has a way for you to add
[Music]
describe a schema in a strongly typed
way so
go back to how this this SQL like task
looks like
calling it get Penguins data here's what
the query that's going to run the
important part here really is the output
schema type take a look at this I'm
telling flight that
you're going to run this this sqlite or
sqlite query and you're going to return
the data using the schema flight's going
to use this schema here with you know
these Columns of specific types that you
chose to do the type matching
so when we call get data let's go back
to the workflow
you call get data
calling get data returning
um that penguin data set passing it to
pre-process data analysis go take a look
at how
pre-processed data looks like
take a look at the input of
pre-processed data it takes a penguins
data set which is a structural data set
set with The Columns of specific types
that you chose which essentially means
if you want to use penguin's data set in
another workflow and the types of match
flight will let you know
um what pre-process data does it's not
terribly interesting let's go back to
the workflow
finally call train model
which is doing
um
actually it's a dynamic task
it's a task that we're going to talk
about the resources later so don't get
too fixated on this but there is a uh
kind of plug-in
that enables you to support you know
external types out of the box so
um for example you know
Python's sequence or
pipe the NN sequential from from
pytharch it's a good example but we have
other kinds of plugins you know
like your for whatever reason using
polars or moding mode or Pandera or Onyx
these are all flight kit plugins that
you can use to
[Music]
um
describe your competition more
ergonomically again what this
training model function is doing is
doing terribly exciting feel free to run
this more locally
in the interest of time I'll always
speed up a little a little bit but I
just wanted to to show that you can have
these Integrations with with
external framework frames
in um very simple way you they integrate
well with the with my type system
um
quiz anymore it's more interesting about
this oh yeah
um
we briefly touched on Dutch idea
um when we were talking about
these slides here
like this
um
this this workflow this like this white
box or white rectangle that you're
seeing there
um what I'm representing there is is a
workflow that takes you know different
input types and output types and it
takes care of like spinning up and down
the the necessary infrastructure to run
that but the interesting bit that I want
to emphasize first is that in order for
you to let's say return a spark data
frame from a task and piping that into
like a python or like a task that uses
like pie torch and you're gonna like run
things on gpus like you don't have to
write the glue code that transforms a pi
spark data frame into a pandas data
frame like flight under the covers
everything is like a flight is giving
you that for free so go back to to here
what I mean is let's say you had you
know in your
um
in your workflow you're using this task
here
let's take a look at this this is a uh
a task that takes a pi spark data frame
as an input and it returns a pi Spark
um data frame as an output
um
if you if you had some data that you're
loading from
some other data source
that was returning like a pandas data
frame and you're piping that into this
test you don't have to
do some casting or
convert the the actual representation
you just
pipe that right meaning let's say you
had let's write this real quick here if
you had something like this uh
had like a
like a workflow
it's got a workflow it's WF
and
you got some data
let's say this this type here is a PD
dot data frame
if you were to call pre-process
die Spark
doing this
flight
it would work the types would match like
you can obviously check the the schema
but
notice What's Happening Here I can get
data we would be returning a data frame
okay and pre-process data Spark
foreign
data frame these are not the same types
but under the covers flight recognizes
that these two types can match and
flight does the conversion for you so
you don't have to write that that glue
code
it's just what I what I mean
which is very powerful and we have these
conversions being done for different
types of of data frame representations
and they all you know are
well you have a question great cool
what's up
multiple people working on
um kind of like an ml orchestration
system and I guess in the flight kind of
vernacular that would be like you know a
lot of workflows kind of coming together
um
if multiple people are like editing a
work in the world and stuff like that
like
how
how can you is there a way in flight to
kind of see what changes are made over
time and like accordingly
or like kind of like a versioning sort
of like mechanism that's a great
question
um when you register a workflow
one of the parameters that you take is a
version so by construction any workflow
or any task has a version
so yeah you'd you'd probably use this
outside of flight to to do the tracking
but the fact that you just cannot write
or Define flight entity that doesn't
have a version associated with that
yeah yeah and also like keep in mind
that you can have multiple projects and
domains so to also help in this this
stratification of like who does what
when you know like you have a team like
what I mean by this is you have a team
that's just iterating you know over over
a model they use project a and like a
like a staging environment at some point
that team decides to go to production
they they use now the combination of
project a and it's called it's called
production
um domain that is the contract between
like that specific team and like other
teams that are using
um that model
you know
so cool
any other questions
going then
have a fair bit
all right
now we shift gears a little instead of
talking about you know plugins and
wait why is this still running
does that make sense give me a sec
this is already finished now
Visual Studio crapped out on me I think
I'm sure they're finished
yeah
all right
sorry
Jupiter books are
great
sometimes
um
let's talk a little bit more about the
type system I already alluded to this
you know we we take care of in-flight to
do this conversion of you know different
representations for data frames but it
doesn't stop there
um
let's flight has this this idea of
um fast registration
um remember when we talked about
this process here
of
um
going caught in someone's machine to
actually running you have to go through
registration which essentially means a
two-step process you need to provide a
Docker image for that you know version
of of your workflow and you need to
teach flight quote unquote about the
actual structure of your workflow it's
this first step that sometimes is to
cumbersome and which is tackled by we
call in Flight fast registration you
don't necessarily need to build Docker
images all the time you can use this
this
cheaper process that we call fast
register that allows you to iterate
faster you still get the benefits of you
know versioning all your workflows but
you're not building images all the time
so we're gonna leverage this for this
example now
Coral type system
example for
again
what's the name of the
yeah so
example is not is not terribly important
let's take a look at
get
data
definition of get data
you know it's just it's loading the
Palmer Penguins State instead and
returning a data frame with some
some format this
this type here is
pens data frame
let's run a quick example here and
instead of having a having this return a
penis data frame it's just no for it
Giggles change the type for get data
from Panzer frame to dect
see what happens when we we try to
register
this using flight so
how do I
carrying the terminal I'm just running
um Pi fight register that specific pair
project and domain
passing the image
that we we built in a previous step I
mean we're not going to build another
image now we're just trying to register
this new version of the workflow and see
what happens
who we get an error
scarier I mean
oh God this is
great
um
just to translate What's Happening Here
we are trying to register a new version
of this task the get splits task
and this thing failed by saying that why
we were trying to compile your workflow
the types don't match
you have a get splits that for this
specific version that were red Stringham
now and it's auto-generated you know for
this particular example
it's on you to choose the version but if
you don't choose the version we just
hash your code produce a hash and use
that as the version
but this is saying hey there's a
mismatching types we expect
that you'd be giving us a structural
data set type but you're giving us a
struct which is in Flight the the flight
type system is how we represent
dictionaries
these types of match you are not allowed
to even register this change
which you know think of having this kind
of change going through a CI process
where right there
um you get
feedback that hey you're you're the
change that you're trying to make anime
it doesn't really doesn't really work
here
potentially
blocking you when you're trying to do
something with you know Pipelines
my system because it's yeah it's very
strict huh
is there a way to ignore that and then
also
um is there is it possible to use like
user defined types
fight or does it have to be
um good two questions so first one
is is there a way to
disable the strict type verification
that you get when you try to register a
workflow the answer is no
like you need to if you if you want to
run or register you know any any piece
of computation is in flight
you are forced to abide by the type
system it's uh I we understand it is uh
it is strict and sometimes it is not
necessarily like the way people work
with with python but
um
we're playing like a longer game here
you know like we want to ensure
correctness at any any point
um
and the second question
I forgot what was the second question
again
oh yeah user defined types of course
item yeah so you can treat it like a
dictionary when you call that method but
not
generally it's not you know
you know the certificate plane
handle that or or can it handle duct
typing like that
great question and the tldr is yes you
will be able to Define your own like
transformation so
and what flight does under the covers is
that it gets the python native types or
whatever language you know you're
programming in and compiles that down to
the fly type system it does that back
and forth so that you never really have
to worry about Wi-Fi type system you're
just if you're just using it as a user
right
if you're defining new user types
there is a contract that you have to to
um abide by to Define this kind of
transformation that you're mentioning
where
I have my own type
I have to use the I want to represent
that using flight type system there is a
escape hatch and it's not terribly
complicated
Does this answer your question so you
can use whatever user defined type that
you want we ship with a lot of
extensions you know I already mentioned
like the modem data frame like Onyx like
there's a lot
in extending that is um
it's pretty simple
okay
um in the interest of time I'm going to
skip these two next examples because I I
really want to talk about caching so
um
let's wait
let's go
caching so
[Music]
sometimes you the the kinds of workloads
that you run on flight is they are very
heavy they run
for an extended period of time so
recognition of this kind of
um of of computation flight gives you
the ability to essentially cache the
results of any intermediate
um task
really so the way you express this using
flight SDK is by
in the task
decorator
let's go to
get data
yeah uh split data so just to refresh
real quick
use the workflow
this time we're changing the type of the
model but it doesn't really matter we
get some data we split it to the model
take a look at the split data
uh
wait why is this correct split data
I don't understand what this means I
don't care
go to definition
oh my God
I want this yes
highlighting here how you can
instruct flight to Cache the results of
any computation
so
you just to set the the cash field to
draw and you give it a version remember
again this ideal version is pervasive in
Flight like you not only version
workflows and tasks
you can also version the data that you
cache
it's all user defined you you YouTube
get picked these the results of running
tasks can be reused across different
workflows even
um different you know project and
domains
but how does this look like when you run
in flight
I can deflate you while I can help to
see
how
what has been cached what are the
versions
that's getting even work
this should run okay so we're interested
in what's going to happen when split
data
runs
um
yeah great see this this little icon
here
this is essentially telling you that the
result of running this specific task was
cached
which means that if we run this workflow
again
you we're not going to pay the cost of
you know executing this you know
separate container we're going to get
the results from the cache
I mean go back to
yeah so
in tune model which is a dynamic dynamic
in in this example like we're calling
split data again and
the result of training model is also
it's also being cached so just go from
this
go back to caching
train model here is
um
being cached with version one
this should run in another
wait
it's being so slow
great so we're almost there
I'm trying to rerun this and see
um
how much faster we can make this
workflow now that we're caching the a
lot of the intermediate steps
toon model the last one we're getting
getting the best model
um I know I I didn't touch on this but
you can
getting spec the actual logs for any of
the containers are running in in the in
your cluster directly from here
um you can configure this to you know
ingest your logs to
um
stackdriver or any other like this these
um platforms let you uh
store logs
so
um let's go
relaunch this
to show that
um
the task
executions
or the cached executions they now they
don't run they don't produce new
containers like see how this this was
essentially
instant
same to tune models
whenever that runs
yeah so
oh man
this is taking its sweet time
demo gods are not happy oh great so yeah
so we we cached the result of all
cultural train model you can see by this
little icon here that everything is
cached we didn't really wait anytime
basically to get
um access to the
results of these previous computations
um in finally
I want to leave some time for a question
so when I skip
these two demos
talk about what at in Flight we call all
flight tax which is essentially this
idea that you can
you can produce
descriptions of your tasks
in in a very
um
ad hocway and what I mean by this is as
long as you describe and you as you can
generate a in some HTML that describes
the result of that task
you are free to
use flight decks so
um let's take a look at this example
real quick
so again
not being anything super special here
have a workflow that does
um it has two tasks one called called
get data another one called get data
annotated let's take a look at get data
first
in get data
we are adding this little bit of of code
here that essentially
creates a new DAC
while you know get data is is being
executed we're calling it data profile
and it's using this this frame profiling
renderer which
um
who summarize the data frame that we're
loading in each one of the cases like in
this case
um
get data
adds the DAC
calling forcibly so you're instantiating
an object of type deck calling it data
proof data and in in the case of the
other task get data annotated
we get a deck again but this time by
simply annotating the output of of the
the task
with um the frame profiling renderer and
annotation so how does this Translate to
a real artifact so let's run
this workflow
this is
slower than I would like but give it
another
second all right cool so
you are not lying like the workflow
Works only two tasks they run in
parallel
but if you now inspect this little
button here that says Flight Deck
now we have a thing that we're calling
data profile remember this is what this
means go back to the code in the case of
get data we produced a deck that we're
calling data profile and it's using this
DAC frame profiling renderer and this is
how it looks like the essentials if we
have the code for this here
yeah so this thing is is just calling
creating a profile report using why data
profiling
you know
data frame summarization package
and you get all this for free this is
HTML that was produced as part of
executing your task
[Music]
um
if you're wondering you get tax for free
for all inputs and outputs in the case
of data frames we just run
um
cat n which you know by default just
shows the top five and the bottom five
rows of of a data frame across and using
all
columns but
you're free to Define
any visualization for your data
even for your user defined
um
objects
here I'm just showing you one case where
again I'm creating this this object
called DAC hack which uses this renderer
but this renderer can be user code
it can be you know you have your
internal representations for for data
you just Define it yourself which is
what the example 11 does
we're not going to go through it because
I just want to make sure that we have
final 10 minutes 10 more questions or
anything that you guys want to talk
about
any questions about Dax
oh yeah
by default it's true
so you have to opt in
um
that's in the works yeah we we are but
right now is part of the reddish version
so as long as part of your code you know
um
great question
all right
um
any other questions before I go back to
the slides
because I have like
a couple more things talk about oh you
do what's up
is that something that's a first class
thing in flight or is it something that
you
'd like
so
um there is no promotion per se
but
um we've seen people deploy a flight
where they build like a small amount of
tooling to just help you like promote
quote-unquote versions across project
and domains
but it's on you essentially
cool
just to summarize
um flight helps you orchestrate compute
data and infrastructure in an ergonomic
way
we love types types safety means a lot
we even you know as you you asked about
like we force people think about types
at least at the boundaries of tasks all
the time
containers are essential
and um
this idea to bring to help you go from
coding your laptop all the way to
production across on multiple teams in a
large org it's always in our minds
there's a lot of Integrations across you
know the data science and ml stack
um if you're curious about llms
um there's a fight talk happening on
Friday where the demo is essentially
talking about or using using llama to
use training or fine-tuning element
model using flight
uh
if you want to get involved
we love our dogs but they can always be
improved you can go to
um
docs.fly.org
and start there make sure to join our
Slack
and all the flight code is open source
if you go to github.com
flights everything's there
it's very actively developed used by a
lot of giants Giant in the in the
industry
quick plug for Union and Union Cloud we
want to help democratize the use of
flight
and you know make sure that people can
can leverage flight to solve solo
problems in the world without having to
worry too much about the infrastructure
we are hiring
please come to the uh the happy hour
that we're sponsoring tomorrow yeah
tomorrow 7 P.M at the local side of
Redmond
and that's my final slide does anyone
have any questions
in that case thank you thank you so much
and I'll be